justin here with a gamespot news update
if you've been dying to buy some fallout
4 merchandise it's your lucky day or
week I guess Bethesda's online store
kicked off a merchandise sale today that
will last the rest of the week the
fallout 4 themed sale is called the
Great War sale event along with
discounts new Fallout branded items will
be introduced throughout the week with
the exception of things like games and
pre sale items almost everything in the
store is twenty percent off including
non fallout items like quake and
wolfenstein t-shirt you can also
pre-order the fallout anthology and all
shipping during the event is free the
store will introduce a new item every
day with the first being a great more
2015 t-shirt that will only be available
for this week Tuesday will be a limited
edition fallout Xbox one controller a
pitbull a messenger bag is coming on
Wednesday Thursday will see a vault Tec
watch and a limited edition art books
will close out the week supply is
supposedly limited for all these items
so if you're interested you better act
fast fallout 4 will be available
November 10th but you probably already
knew that or even more news stay tuned
to gamespot